taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking hey taste buddies
it's the taste bud
show with sal and joe
baby how you doing i'm hurting a little
bit today
i see it in the eyes i know you saw it
as soon as i walked in you and pimp knew
you had you had a you have a sheen a
glaze
you
did you begin drinking i had friends in
from out of town it's always the death
kiss
they wanted to come to the pop-up to try
the sandwiches
so they showed up at 2 30. i had my
first post meridian
post mourinho no no eastern no wait post
morning pm yeah
let's see the case you build for your
foods today buddy
uh they showed 2 30 p.m this is making
it
no it's i feel good about it yeah i want
one of those
uh we had our first drink at 2 30.
at 4 30 they were like we got to go to
this russian vodka restaurant
to get dinner with a friend and they go
do you want to come and i'm like yeah
they throw the vodka right on the table
they didn't do that but we had
many martinis at this place okay and but
we ate a nice meal
chicken kiev what not you know martinis
yeah
which is funny because you wanted to
take a margarita and go up against me
with a martini which we'll do
oh yeah you texted me a picture of you
drinking martini yesterday i didn't say
i don't like martinis
because i'll take a marg anything you
gotta pry a mark out of my hands dude
but that's that's for another time i'm
ready that's for another time i'm ready
so uh
but anyway so then we go there so then i
go let's go back to my place
so we all go back to my place how many
just four of us okay was their friend
and my friends
uh paul and rachel who i haven't seen in
four years okay but they're so you drink
of a good reason yeah these are
these are lifelong friends though okay
you know okay
that they live down south so i don't see
them often uh so anyway so then we go
to my place everybody's is everybody on
the same drinking plane
pretty much okay we get more beer so
everybody's on board yeah we get beer
yeah that's the best way we start doing
shots in my place now
yes everybody yeah shots then
the edibles came out and i did some
edibles and i never do that
i never do that wipe
that smug smirk off of your face
how dare you what how dare you what
i can't get you to do an edible to save
my life
and you're out doing edibles will nil
they were only five mills dude five mils
five mils when you don't do edibles it's
enough to put you right on your ass
well tell me about it i'm feeling it
today i'm on my ass today what what do
they have that i don't have
that you'll do edibles with them you
come to my house it's just
whatever you want whenever you need you
can never always
say no you're son of a [ __ ] i will go
downstairs
i will go downstairs okay i have
at least ten different products that are
five milligrams each you
shut your mouth here's what i need on an
head here's what i need
i have a 2.5 all right here's what i
need uses i need a
and i need a [ __ ] and drink and weed
responsibly it's legal now
god bless it helps with the you know my
stresses and
what have you this is what i need on an
edible i need to sit
and look at the wall and have some crazy
music on and get real
into the music and get bugged out here's
what i don't need on it now
you're not taking acid here's what i
don't need this i'm just telling you
what i like on a marijuana edible
you become anti-social a little bit i
know that you do because the only time
i've ever had you do it with me
you've excused yourself both times and
said i need to retreat to a mattress
and you close the door and you lay in
bed fully clothed and stare at the
ceiling
for one to three hours and then you
emerge back out
right because in my defense in my
defense
and those hangs in one corner you got
jay okerson
trying to tell you a 47-minute story
and indeed he's a great storyteller he
is but i'm saying sometimes i'm not in
the headspace forum okay
not an edible in the other corner you
got ari god knows what he's capable of
doing right yeah
and sometimes it's not that comfortable
so who are these
who this ragtag motley crew you with
yesterday
flow like wine my old buddy paul who
knew when we ate the edible all we were
gonna do was sit there
and play each other genesis songs and
tell the other guy how brilliant
i would do that i could do it with just
you i'm saying
you think you're going to get wings
chris doesn't do edibles
i always love him he says no now he has
a whole patreon
wait does edibles i'm showing what i'm
saying remember remember the previous
edible hang on what is it with me it's
not you it was just you and me i would
eat the edible
or or i would have stayed in the room
but you don't you're not getting wig nut
and
large tail to sit down
and listen to the ocean
wing nut and bart's tail they're out of
that fence too much
can't do it are you
[Laughter]
you know for a guy who's dull around the
senses coming off yesterday you're
pretty sure
i know how to turn it on baby i know how
to turn it off would you guys ever do an
edible episode
i would never do one on camera because i
get it would
be a nightmare to me i also by the way
have to be just real quick
i have to be shit-faced
drunk before i could even consider even
so most nights
[Laughter]
at any given moment then you're ready
for an animal uh
no you know myself i didn't get into
marijuana until
just a few years ago my whole life but
now i'm
well versed and i i feel like i could do
one on because i don't even get that
high anymore
that you get when you first start and
you're like oh my god
i didn't know i thought that was how
everyone got
any time they had weed and i would look
at my friends that smoked
um often or sometimes daily and i said
how
how in the world are they functioning i
didn't realize there was a weed
tolerance and that
that they're just like you get to a
point where the wheat is just kind of
like
taking the edge off then you got to
reset everything my question is this so
i feel like i i wouldn't get that high
where it would be like oh my god i gotta
hide that i've watched i've watched you
and jay and ari smoke weed
and i've noticed you guys will hit a
point where any one of you or all three
of you will grow
i'm good on this and you put out the
joint yeah my question to you is this
because it's been so long dude i was
i was a habitual pot smoker when i was
in college
and into my early 20s uh daily pot
smoker and uh
i i just hit a wall with it where i had
a couple
panic attacks and i was like i don't
like this anymore and ever since then
it's never been the same
which is why i rarely ever touch it but
my question is
i always wondered that with you because
i don't remember
when you go i'm good on this if i said
i'm good on
if i spoke to joint right now and i said
i'm good on this that would be me
literally saying like
i'm going to have a panic attack if i
get any higher but you're
so what's the learned it's like how you
become an expert drinker
you know like how you know how to
navigate where i'm not going to get sick
i'm not going to get
drunk i'm not going to go over the top
of course we all falter right but
but yeah it's just like you know it
depends when it's one of two things most
likely it's that
uh i know that this will be enough to
just you know i'm just coast i'm not
looking to get crazy like
whatever you know so i took a few puffs
and i'll wait again if i'm gonna do it
again or i'm good
it's just like understanding of where my
own tolerance is but
another version is like it's not gonna
do anything
right but that's the least version but
when i'm like really smoking a lot and
well maybe that's not true
but sometimes it's just like you know
you hit a ceiling
no matter how much you smoke if you're
smoking that much
so it's almost just like yeah i'm there
i'll wait i have a question for you guys
have you ever gone on stage high i can't
imagine
the worst feeling in the world i did it
two times and
i it was it was horrible it was horrible
i'll never do it ever i don't think
we're talking that turn here but someone
like jay
who's he's an avid smoker and like i
think he like smoke he he
likes to smoke before it goes on stage
yeah and that's because he's gotten to
that place like
for me uh i never the only times i ever
was high on stage were when i didn't
really smoke
and so by uh one and both two times were
accidental
and then i had spots and had to do it
and uh
and i got on stage and i had a
full-blown panic attack and i thought
everybody was staring at me and i forgot
all my lines
all my jokes and everything and i was
like i literally was like trembling on
stage
i had a real they used to do a show in
new york
um i won't say where they did it because
i don't want to get anybody in trouble
but there was a show i can't remember
the name of it either
where you'd you'd get high and go on
stage they do that now
that was the hook i think that literally
no joke they asked me if i wanted to do
that at the stand like this week i think
it's something i call like
something high show this was like you
eat edibles
and then you go on stage no way yeah
this was like a big deal at the time
because it was like
it was it was like an edgy thing to do
right you know like pot was edgy at one
point you know
but like we uh i don't even know if i
call it pot or weed yeah
uh that is a little bit like uh it's
long
yeah pot you're a little long in the
tooth it's uh
but i went you'd smoke you want to do
pot tonight and then you hit
and then you go on stage you don't look
good
you won't you want so much pot last
night
so much pot you think you know pot
you got to see how much pot i potted
real pot you you'd smoke
but then you couldn't go on you got a
pot dealer oh yeah
you couldn't smoke in the venue yeah
because it was not
okay obviously so like you had to smoke
elsewhere
at a location and then a given location
designated location excuse me
and then you'd all go over to the venue
yeah together and um
i remember i did it with giannis i did
the show with giannis
i yadas he smoked too you mean you just
you know we were both honest
okay giannis as soon as we got to the
venue he goes i'm never doing this
show again he walked outside and walked
circled the block in the rain for an
hour
yeah that's like the real high and i get
in the beginning yeah and i made a
mistake of
i said when we were smoking i had a
little bit i probably wouldn't find i go
come on if we're doing this let's do it
i want to get like high high
yeah because that's what you think it is
all the time and you get zooted and you
can sit there for six hours just with
your own thoughts
yeah and i had a full i'm not
exaggerating i had a real panic attack
like where you feel like the the room is
closing in you feel like you need to go
to the emergency room
you know what i mean yeah and uh uh
what's his name
uh james uh uh harris
jf harris yeah yeah congrats to jf has
he just filmed his uh first special oh
congrats
buddy he sat with me for an hour
he's a good dude like that and got me
water and talked me down
and was like bro you don't need to go to
the emergency room you're going to be
fine
and he got me normal enough that i was
able to eventually go on stage
yeah oh my god and the stage experience
still sucked
uh but it's it was i didn't i wasn't
freaking out anymore at least you know
three times high first time accidentally
ate a weed
infused apple pie that was brought to my
set and i just thought it was crafty
wow and it was like 30 milligrams or
something like that or 100 milligrams
somebody get fired for that no no
because the person who brought it like
did everyone a favor and brought brought
it i just
i did i wasn't there when they presented
it and after wrap we had a post
uh post filming like powwow and so i
went and i just grabbed a piece and i'm
eating the pie
and like i have like two a bite or two
left and q is like where'd you get that
pie
and went in like a big circle with
everybody and i'm like it was at the
crafty and he's like
he goes out he goes that is full on
wheat
i didn't smoke at a time and then my
first
my friend who brought it told me it was
like it was like 30 or 100 i don't know
i think it was 30 milligrams
and i got so nervous for someone who
doesn't smoke that's hospital yeah yeah
they said hurry up they got a pa to get
me in my car with me
and drive me home immediately and then i
i didn't want to face what
the wrath of the 30 so i got home went
straight to bed i had a spot at gotham
that night
at 9 30. it was like a juice show or
something right
and so i went to bed and i set my alarm
for eight o'clock i got home at like one
two o'clock i said i slept six hours
woke up was high as [ __ ]
really yes i told my girlfriend i was
like babe you gotta drive me
to to gotham i i i felt bad to cancel
so she got in the car drove me back to
the city
right i went i got into gotham i walked
in i go i want to let you guys know i'm
very high
i i took an edible that has lasted nine
hours and counting
and i'm gonna go on stage i want to
cancel it but i don't know what i'm
doing right now
and i got on stage and i said that i
said guys i accidentally
ate wheat apple pie this afternoon i
said i had to be driven here
i don't know what's going on and it was
actually a
great set because they were it didn't
matter what i said they were crying
because that was so high other two
experiences not good
i was i remember a time yeah
i smoked doing the goddamn comedy jam
that was one of them at moon tower
that was one of the moon tower comedy
festival where you left
we thought you bailed on the show yes
because you got too stoned and we were
like
everybody's like i think sal just bailed
everybody and then you went on
stage ended up killing you had a great
set but like i don't know where you went
for that hour
and i know what happened like what had
happened was i had a weed
tincture spray right it was like a it
was like a banaca
but it was weed right and my buddy who
shall go unnamed
was with me for that trip in austin and
my other friend was holding that
tincture spray
and we were all backstage like 50 comics
there and he was just walking up to
everybody and spraying them in the mouth
and was five a spray and my friend who
was with me
didn't know that that was weed and then
just saw everyone taking like
banaca so my friend opened his mouth and
my friend hit him with a few sprays
he didn't know it was weed so my friend
who's never smoked weed before
an hour later we're backstage waiting to
go on
on on on stage for the goddamn connor he
goes
sal i am not something's happening to my
body i said i
i don't i don't feel well and it feels
weird and i don't know the feeling
but i'm a little concerned i'm going to
go outside and get some air i said
you'll be all right buddy we're in a
small space you know we've been hanging
out all night maybe you need some water
or something
i go on in in uh in two people and two
sets i go on
i go go outside and i'll be right out i
wait like five minutes
and he comes back in again he goes sal
it's getting worse
rapidly he goes i almost can't breathe
i'm freaking out now imagine
if you don't smoke weed and you take
about 15 milligrams but you don't know
it yeah imagine what you feel what's
going on if you don't have a panic
attack
he started to have a panic attack i'm
like you gotta be and then he goes i
hate to do this too but i'm gonna leave
i have to go to the hospital
i'm not leaving you i didn't know what
was wrong with him right i go don't
worry about it i'll just tell him i
can't go on it's more important than
that
they'll find another comic there's a
hundred here right so i hit up josh and
i go josh i gotta run out
my friend i don't know if he got
poisoned or roofied
or something something's happening to
him i might have to go to the hospital
hit bump me to the last spot if i get
back in time fine if not i'll keep in
touch on text
so i go outside and he's
hyperventilating he's like
i can't take this anymore i i can't
believe it's getting worse so i go i'm
[ __ ]
that's it let's go get help we run out
of the alley we're in a back alley wait
no
are you stoned while this is happening i
am stoned but
no no no i i also took weed but i didn't
get stoned yet
but i also didn't realize and this
doesn't happen too often i took
too much because that spray is easy to
just so i didn't realize so i took too
much on top of this now
not yet yeah i know at the right time so
we run into his famous steakhouse that's
at
on the corner it's like a really i've
eaten there before it's like this
high-end place
they're almost closing but i think my
friend is dying we don't know why
so i burst in i'm half high i'm half
high he's higher than he's ever been in
his life and thinks he's dying
and i'm trying to articulate to the to
the manager and
the people there that are working at
that we need help but i'm high and i go
please excuse me it was real close i go
i don't need to eat i go
my friend i think he might be dying he
doesn't know
i go i need i need to get water
he's going to pass out i don't know i
got to call up and the guy goes
i guess he didn't want a liability of my
friend he thought he was dying you had
to get out i go pull him please sir
please and he said get out get it throws
us out and now my friend's like
i don't know what to do and i go i'm
calling 9-1-1 so i call 9-1-1
i tell them the venue we're at now all
the comics are in the alley and they go
in and out by the alley
the front is there's nobody in front but
that's where the whole crowd went in
i tell them the front address three or
three ambulances a fire truck a police
truck they all screech up in front of
the place
before they get there i'm looking and i
go mike
think think did anything happen out of
the order he was like no
he's like that friend of yours though he
he
sprayed me and i was like he sprayed you
and he goes yeah yeah
and he goes i think it was him he goes
how well do you know him
and i go what do you mean he's he's my
he's my friend he's like
he's like my friend he's my good friend
he goes
you know him that well he goes that
[ __ ] tried to poison me
he goes that guy tried he goes that guy
tried to poison me i go what are you and
i go oh my god
i go did he spray a minty spring do you
mind he goes diego's mike go that's my
weed spray i go he's probably he goes he
was walking around spraying everybody i
go
you didn't know it was weed he goes no i
go why'd you open your mouth he goes i
don't know he walked up put it at my
mouth so i opened it
which is which is a weird thing to do
but he thought it was like
like a bananaka because it tasted like
mint it's weird if a man's walking
around a room with a banana i'm not
opening it
you want something so you're going to
take a shot
so i go mike look at me you're high as
[ __ ] i promise you
you're gonna be okay eventually i don't
think you should get into this ambulance
and he's like all right did i just say
his name it's okay yeah so it's okay no
one knows
yeah so so so then moments later the
ambulances screech up
and i'm like i'm telling you you're
gonna be we're gonna you're gonna be
stuck there all night so the guy they
all come up
they all like have him stop filling that
paperwork and he goes we go listen
we're gonna forego everything we're
sorry but he was having
i guess a panic attack and now he's okay
and you could tell the guy
from the from the emt he knew exactly
and he goes
now he's okay i go yeah he goes okay
so you understand what's happening then
yeah he goes
okay he goes because we'll take him he
goes but
understand if he comes with us now it
was like a [ __ ] show at the hospital
yeah
he's like at 2 a.m on a saturday night
he'll be
in the hospital till tomorrow right he's
like so
think about what you want to do and
we're like no no we're good we're good
so he had to sign a waiver like forgo it
and then we went back in now at this
time when they pull away
i get hit hard i i guess it just
it came in late now i walk back in the
alley with him he's like has a watering
just standing in the corner like shaking
and i and then i see josh i'm like i'm
so sorry i'm back and he goes all right
this still
you could go on last the second and last
and i get up there and i was
i was so high and i that's the saving
grace
because i think i told them i might have
told them i don't know
very good set i don't know but the other
time i did it i just i didn't know i was
going on
and yeah and they passed around a joint
and so i took two puffs and then
someone's like you want to jump up
tonight
and i forgot that i took the two puffs
they asked me right after i go yeah
and then by the time i got on i got on
stage i swear to you
and i just wanna guess yeah and i was
just
staring at everyone and then i i just i
was like
six minutes because i was like dropping
like i was just a little guest thing
yeah
and i just and i just apologized i
talked to a few people in the crowd like
you would talk to a passerby
there was no jokes i apologize and then
i went out and i hid in the alley
that's the old stand the crowd was
excited to see you yeah and they would
and i just was like i don't even
understand
there was one point where i thought i
was telling jokes
and then i realized i was completely
silent
yeah the other time i did it was the
same thing i was on a date with a with a
somebody and and she we went to her
apartment it was a very early date for
some reason and we smoked weed
and then i remember i was so s
high i went into the bathroom
i had to pee twice while i was there and
i went and peed after the second time i
peed i came out and i was i was so high
and paranoid that i just go
i just want you to know i'm not like a
cokehead
she's like what are you talking about
what are you talking about you don't
have to be worried around me as
obviously i'm not going to do anything
to you yeah yeah
like i just keep going to the bathroom i
want you to think i'm a coke head she's
like
what i was like i'm sorry i'm high
and i was walking back i don't know
where i would i don't know why i was
walking through
i guess she lived in the west village
and it was early and it was like eight
o'clock and
i walked by the village lantern and they
were like do you want to go on and i
remember it was one of the first times i
ever got
asked do you just want to go on at a
place like it was like
this is a place that i'd actually would
wait and book spots at you know like
so i was like so blown away like oh i
can just go on in this place
so i went on and it was the same thing
dude i couldn't remember any jokes i
thought the audience all knew that i was
high
it was terrible dude i bombed so bad oh
i missed those highs though not that
experience but
you gotta i did it i you know you just
stop i stopped like three full months
and then i
my first like half a joint i smoked
again put me on my ass for like eight
hours
so you gotta do it you gotta like just
stop and slaughter him
slurpee first milkshake yeah wow
speaking of
where are we you ever have a product
that is so confident they give a 100
money-back guarantee uh you know what
i've seen it seldomly well magic spoon
does it
when i see it i like it and i like that
the magic spoon don't you like when
someone stands behind their product like
that
i love it they're a market disruptor
magic spoon
they are they're they're bringing back
delicious fun cereal but through a
healthy lens
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein
four net carbs in each serving 140
calories keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb gmo free
all the buzzwords they check them all
build your own box
a lot of different flavors i got a
bundle of four the other day i got
frosted
cocoa peanut butter and fruity and my
favorite cereal is froot loops and i had
the fruit
magic spoon and it is it's a little
closer to uh fruity pebbles but it is a
banger i love the uh i'm
i am also a big fan of the fruit flavors
uh that they
offer i like mixing blueberry with fro
fruity
and i find that that really creates a
really nice bouquet if you will
of uh flavors uh in the fruit department
it's a
wonderful company it's a wonderful
product and it's it's awesome that we're
in this place now nutritious
new in the it's awesome that the field
nutrition is allowing us to eat stuff
this tasty
that's actually not bad for you i did do
a peanut butter chocolate the other
night
that's nice i did and it really felt
like a treat go to magicspoon.com
tastebuds to grab a custom bundle of
cereal
and try today and be sure to use the
promo code tastebuds check out to save
five dollars off your order
remember your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal it's at magicspoon.com
tastebuds and use the code tastebuds
to save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon we love you
appreciate you sponsoring the episode
why do you need a vpn
i'll tell you why because the internet's
a shady place
and people are tracking what you're
doing and i'm not saying that like
you're doing anything wrong
i'm just saying people are looking at
your stuff they're getting your
information
you're not secure you need a secure
vpn service to use and there's none
better than expressvpn
they create a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device
and the internet so people can't peep at
your online activity don't forget like
i'm not saying you're doing anything you
shouldn't be doing
but your numbers are out there your
names your addresses all these things
you got to protect yourself you have it
on your laptop
i have it there and i have it on my
phone and look there's places like cnet
wire the verge those big name places
they all rate this as the number one vpn
yeah
it's great and it's so easy to use it's
awesome well i've really enjoyed you i
got into the point where i got it like a
few years back and i just do the annual
and uh i feel i don't like to go online
now without it feels like my protection
feels like you're naked yeah yeah it
feels like i'm naked yeah so anyway
here's what i want you to do we want you
to go visit expressvpn.com
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com taste buds and you're going to
get
an extra three months free
expressvpn.com
taste buds you're going to get an extra
free three months when you sign up
oh my god
all right you're taking slurpee i'm
taking milkshakes yeah
yeah you hit me up with it you you
suggested this challenge i said
i don't see these two competing you said
they are both
dessert drinks that are sugary that you
have
you know and and you're right you're
absolutely right yeah they're they're
drink
and even brought it broaden it a little
more than just dessert drinks
they're treats the treats they're sweet
treats as we've you said before on the
show about other things
yeah and you know the point here is is
this is a uh a dessert style drink that
you drink
as a thing as an item guilty pleasures
yeah
they're both loaded with with with sugar
so you don't you're not like
it's not an everyday drink it's a
special occasion it's not an everyday
drink and i
you know as much as happy days tries to
make us think that people drink
milkshakes as their beverage
uh i don't think that that's the the
standard okay you know i
you know i'm sure some people do but you
know i don't think that that's common
that
people are getting slurpee i confused at
first with slushy because i don't i
haven't really purchased many
slurpees in my life which is the
7-eleven specific exclusive brand
of what would you call it a ice cream an
ice
beverage a nice chopped ice yeah what do
you call that
it's it's along the lines of of a water
you know it's it's
it's a water ice family right uh it's
it's a
but it is what i used to rock at the
movie theater and
kmart they do something a little bit
different with a slushie i'm not quite
sure
polar bear on it right he's got it's the
red and blue is he the same polar bear
from the ice cubes
isn't there ice cubes with a polar bear
um mascot no
it's just he's just icy slushy slushie
was my jam
not so spicy is the polar bear oh it is
icy oh so what's that that's the one
that's the movie theater
so that's the movie theater oh so why am
i thinking of slushy slushy is more
of like chipped ice with like
slushie is more more of a drink
consistency so slushie isn't a brand
name it's the generic name yeah
but okay scroll down pimp no no go back
to those photos
scroll a little bit more right there see
that
that's a slushie that's what sonic does
sonic's okay sonic's famous for their
slushies no no so i'm talking about an
icy
yeah i see way more like a slurpee for
me
for me i see straight-up
routes a slurpee i don't
understand what that means what does
that mean
i like an icy better than a slurpee i
think it dominates a slurpee you're
that's an insane story i understand
they're very similar they come from the
same time
slurpee is oh coca-cola's in charge of
that
well i know they have the cola flavored
they have a coca-cola not a cola
a coca-cola flavor i thought it was cold
you get the cola flavored slurpee and
you mix it with the cherry
the wild cherry that's always on deck at
a 7-eleven
i mean get get out of it cherry icee is
was my go-to at the movie theater for a
long time as a kid
until i realized that with every single
icy i drank
i was closer to death yeah right it's
red dye number five with straight up uh
uh a corn syrup high fruct yeah there's
nothing like that
i mean it's it's it's it's literal
terrible sugar syrup mixed with
what do you call that kind of ice is it
is it like i guess is it like uh
i don't know that's why i want to be
sure that's why
i need to to say here what i am
defending today
and i'm going on record here i am
defending specifically
the 7-eleven slurpee i am not defending
the ic i am not the
shade of ice it's not it's it's
it's a it's a it's a it's almost like an
ice that's cream but not cream
there's got to be a word i don't
understand how they blended ice
yeah i guess it's blended probably right
while slurpee is a brand name a slushie
is that you
cannot make a slurpee at home that's why
i'm saying this
you need the machine yes you need that
special
machine also shout out wawa
but i mean the slurpee is the king of
all
slushy drinks i would i'd probably agree
here's
well you just said you think that icy
routes it i do but i think slurpee's
king that doesn't mean
okay now here's a trick i learned with
the slurpee it'll be life-changing for
anybody that's got slurpee beefs
because i'm sure some of you have run
into the problem with the slurpee
where you go yeah but you suck on the
straw and it just makes a hole to the
bottom and then you gotta pull out the
straw put it back in do it again
that's because you've got too much air
in your slumber you're saying stuff so i
don't have to i have a laundry list of
complaints about my slurpee i'm just
gonna i'm gonna put i'm gonna put the
kybash from this right out of the gate
today
you got too much air in your slurpee
here's what you do i've been doing this
for at least 20 years now
you go in 30 years i'd even say you go
in
you fill up about an inch into your cup
with slurpee
you take that cup you bang it on the
countertop this gets all the air out of
it
you do it again with another inch bang
it on the countertop get some of the air
out
you are walking it sounds like a delight
you were watching you know you're doing
hard labor now you're not only walking
away with a with a very drinkable slur
you're packing a pack of cigarettes that
you don't have to take the straw in out
of
you're walking away with a heavier
slurpee you're getting a lot more
bang for your buck you're getting a full
load
i don't need a a life hack in order to
even enjoy a treat as it's meant to be
enjoyed i mean
you you have every one of your treats
how many drinks you put in your pocket
that's not the only problem
how many treats do you put in your
pocket you hack all of your treats every
one treat you talk about is a hack
what do you mean everything you talk
about in the show explain you gotta let
it melt for a while i gotta roll around
in my mouth so i can then suck the
middle part out first
i gotta let it soak those are the
preferences in which i consume
you're telling me you need to do this so
you don't have issues what you treat
no i'm just saying the too much air
argument isn't valid because
if you know what you're doing it's not a
thing i guess if you know what you're
doing i guess it's like saying i don't
like white
it's like saying i don't like white wine
because it's warm and it's like well you
because you got to freeze it
it's not like saying that okay so now
you need a hack just to not be sucking
out down your trach
right now how about this one how about
when you suck because it also comes with
those straws of the the
the width of the holland tunnel yeah so
you get a little spoon you suck it on
that which is a little spoon
unapologetic like you they're asking you
to really heave in a lot you need some
some force
to begin the momentum to get the slurpee
which is already a little thick
like a milkshake into that straw that is
literally the
like i say it's a tube now you're
sucking it up i fear for you
i fear for your cardiovascular health
the milkshake has the same problem so
the the same answer is no no no the last
time is much worse let it sit a little
no no the milkshake problem
is much worse i i've never had a a a a
suction problem
with a slurpee ever comes right yeah
you're not being
not be straightforward i'm being
straightforward that's that's especially
true that's a tremendous lie who's got
trouble
sucking a slurpee up to a straw because
when when you get a slurpee because not
all
not every time the machine's doing the
right stuff for you behind the scenes
so sometimes you go and you pull and
it's a watery slurpee sometimes you go
and you pull it's a very aerated slurpee
when you have an aerated server no
matter how much you bang
it's light and fluffy you know if you
get a large and you pick it up it's
still light there's a lot of fluff
wrong you don't the mechanics are wrong
you don't know the bang trip i don't
need to know the banker what point is
when you get it by the way that watery
thing you let it ride for a second it
turns back into
proper slurpee that's just stuff in the
nozzle that was melting down that
happens in every drink yeah i'm talking
about when the actual
slurpee machine it's got its its
measurements off
and it's shooting out stuff that's
lackluster
at least when you walk away you got a
broken slippery machine why are you
drinking a slurpee
i mean if you want to make it that
simple but i'm just telling you the
problems that that slurpees present
imagine i want a slurpee i'm thinking
about it all day i screech into a
parking lot
parallel park first try uh my spirits
are high i walk in it's a sunny day
some i go to the server machine it's no
good you tell me you're not have
milkshake problems
you're not even having milk first of all
your yard's full of boys
okay first of all how long have you been
waiting to drop
that off i thought of it just now
now you got milkshake problems
strawberry [ __ ] is it an issue when it
brings
every boy to the yarn does the slurpee
do it
doesn't slurpee do that common milkshake
problem
milkshakes the only thing that brings
every boy to the yard
ice cream milkshake like a strawberry
for example how many times is a [ __ ]
strawberry
getting lodged in that straw and ruining
your experience that's not a rude
experience
that's a fun little treat it's a fun
treat you know what you do it doesn't
get too far up you pull the straw out
you bite it with your teeth and then you
pull the straw and you pop that
that's sweet a little treat strawberry
right back into your mouth now you're
eating real fruit how about now you're
eating real fruit
people eat proof of vitamins how about a
milkshake that gets handed to you that
you find that was made with powder
how about when you get how about this
that happens that happens how do you
know when you
how do you find out it was made with
powder most fast food places use powder
to make their milkshakes yeah i don't
know anything about that yeah
i mean you know okay sometimes it could
taste good but it's you know but here's
you
by taste you know it's powdered here's
the worst problem and i have asked this
question
every time i've ordered a milkshake i've
asked this question because i do not
like a vanilla shake
i say every time is your chocolate
milkshake real
or are you putting chocolate syrup into
vanilla ice cream
and most of the time i get back we have
vanilla that we put syrup into to flavor
why wouldn't they just use chocolate ice
cream
because they're cheap and this is what a
shitty milkshake now you're getting into
a territory that you do every time well
you're arguing with me
when you have a a milkshake made the way
you don't like it
okay okay we're talking about you were
bringing up sloppy problems
but but but slurpee like by and large
you go to the machine and you pull it
it's not like people are messing it up
on you
so there's more consistency in how you
receive the slurpee i'm saying a lot of
times it's too watery but here's another
thing
okay then if you don't drink it fast
enough
it starts to liquefy into just
sugar water i don't know and it's deep
red
and you you feel no one feel your
arteries
and your your taste buds and you feel it
it gets
so tart that your your your tongue
starts doing a little like
nobody it's just too much nobody in
history
this type of a spike of of pure sugar
just
red like just just straight up
all right but it's all right it's got to
be it's got to be amongst it
amongst the most processed foods in the
entire planet
it's the most processed drink it is ice
cream's
healthy no but at least it's you see the
glass of it is all-natural you couldn't
eat an organic
shake you could drink an organic shape
finding one but i'm saying the
ingredients from a shake are
could becoming all natural
nobody in history has ever drank a
slurpee too slow that's what the brain
freeze it was an all
ad campaign that centered on brain
freeze
it's everybody gets the slurpee headed
because you never drink it too slow
you go too fast with sentences like
nobody in history nobody
will you please for my sake in the
listeners stop
making these blanket absolutists
statements
too slow too slow i do it all the time i
if i
don't know what you're doing if i go if
you drink a milkshake too slow it's
disgusting because it turns into milky
that's that's the actually that's one of
the benefits of the milkshake
if you wait out the milkshake it gets
better if you take too long on the
slurpee it gets worse
okay if i'm going to see like like ice
cream dances with wolves
and i buy a 32 ounce icee i'm not going
to pound
32 or ounces of icee in the first
previews
you think ice cream water until at least
you know who's getting like the middle
of dances with walls
to drink some more and at that point
cold
red syrup you can't get a slurpee at the
movies you're talking about an icee
i think same thing it's isis ics are a
lackluster version of the slurpee i
would never get a slurpee at the movies
even if they were slurpees
why because once again i would never
make a slurpee my drink with something i
was eating
the slurpee once again did you say that
already huh did you say that
yeah i said at the top these are not
drinks you drink as your drink with food
you don't think that people drink their
slurpees at the movie or slushies at the
movie or i sees at the movie
with popcorn chocolate i ain't calling
any accoutrements are you talking about
the
ices at the movies i'm talking about
sarpy's and why
so you kick open you kick open the
7-eleven door goes
you walk up to the slurpee buy a
64-ounce big gum slurpee
and you walk out i don't think you don't
buy you don't buy any bugles
you don't buy no i drink my slurpee and
i walk and by the way
i get the regular sized one you don't
get a hot dog this is why it's melting
on you you're getting a big gulp-sized
slurpee it's just
i don't even order slurpees at 7-eleven
i'm just talking about what they offer
they offer you to put that [ __ ] in a
bucket
disgusting a nice pint-sized slurpee and
that's just enough
that's just enough and also a slurpee
another fun thing
it's you can mix all the flavors you're
the chef
you can put whatever you want together
and it's amazing you can do that without
you can have a shower you mix flavors
i do it all the time maybe two you can
get two you can get two
flavors you go you go into three
flavored territory with a shake you're
in trouble
baby slur a slurpee lower end of the
ladder man that's some low brow [ __ ]
that's some possible wt stuff right
there shout out wt's
you know i'm just saying right god but
that's a
milkshake is decadence it's cream
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's ice
cream it's a treat
it goes hand in hand with a delicious
people have it
with a burger and fries may have rise
with that
shake you know what i mean it's it's
like a thing that people do
it's like i don't know man warby parker
i like what they're doing
they've taken the industry by storm yeah
really yeah they've really come on
strong and hard because they have high
quality glasses they have a lot of
different frames and styles and they
start at 95 bucks
and i am sold immediately well and i'll
tell you this too i like that there's a
little rebellion
uh and and and loftiness to what they're
doing at warby parker i like that
they've created this boutique
boutique quality eyewear at a
revolutionary price point and i also
like
that they're making this as easy as they
can for you
you go on you pick some stuff you like
you maybe five frames right
you say i want to see what i look like
in these they send it to your house you
try them on
you pick out the ones you like you send
them back and then you get your glasses
in the mail it's that easy i'm being so
convenient as a lifelong glasses wearer
i like anybody making the glasses
experience better because i've come from
a time when
every pair was 450 and you got
one yeah you got one and you better not
break it sit on it or lose it that was
it
now you can have a whole variety all
different styles they also do sunglasses
you got
you have any sunglasses from them i
actually have prescription sunglasses
which is another game changer and now
they're also doing contact lenses
uh they give eye exams glasses start at
95 bucks including prescription
lenses uh sunglasses progresses blue
light lenses also available
try warby parker's you mentioned it free
home uh try on program you order five
pairs they send them to you
you try them on no obligation they ship
free prepaid to ship it back
it doesn't get easier than that try five
pairs of glasses at home for free
at warbyparker.com
tastebuds you come here for the food
arguments but we give you a high end
value
on a lot of other beautiful products mac
welding i'm loving these guys man i
needed some
i needed some gear for the summer and
you know joey derozan has summer gear
yeah they uh they uh they have
reinvented some men's basics over there
i'm loving it full collection they got
t-shirts they got polos they got
button-ups they got shorts they got
pants they got swims you got to love a
company that's based on essentials
it's like a one-stop shop you go in
there you get your underwear your pants
your windbreakers your jackets your
t-shirts
solid colors good fits you got some
killer socks
i got some killer socks for them i got a
bunch of jogger pants swim line they got
trunks now yeah i really like i really
really like their stuff
if you're a guy on the go or maybe
you're a young professional
you don't have a lot of time to shop
maybe you stop by mack welding you do a
checklist you just
you just run the whole thing yeah you
just run everything you pick out all
your basics you pick out your essentials
and now you got things to layer you got
things to build off of
anyway that's how i do it yeah and i
like that the swimsuits by the way is
one of my favorite things with a
swimsuit when it's fast drying and it
has a four-way stretch fabric that
they're using oh i love when my
swimsuits have a four-way stretcher
who doesn't like that mac weldon's got a
free loyalty program it's called weldon
blue
uh the level one gets you free shipping
for life wow
at level two if you spend 200 bucks you
get 20 off
every order for the next year jesus so
stay cool this summer with mack weldon
and look good at while you're doing it
all right go to macweldon.com
taste buds and enter promo code taste
buds that's mac
m-a-c-k weldon w-e-l-d-o-n
dot com slash taste buds use the promo
code taste buds
and you're gonna get 20 off 20 off mac
weldon reinventing
the basics for men as a slurpee is just
like
i gotta i would love to take a poll of
people that get slurpees and ask them
how they're doing
they really i would love to ask them how
they're doing i guarantee you a very
high percentage of people that are
buying
slurpees at 7-eleven they got issues
they want to talk about
i want to see i want a milkshake it's
like a kid can have it an adult could
have it
it's a treat a wedding the venetian oh
this argument that slurpees are age
restrictive
no but how many how many 60 year old
people you see
70 000 slurpees a day are sold
that doesn't mean it doesn't i'm talking
about i'm talking about where they are
on the cast system
a slurpee is a national free slurpee day
slurpee 7-eleven is the cornerstone of
7-eleven is the slurpee
it's what made 7-eleven 7-eleven i'm not
saying
i'm not opposed to any of this i'm just
letting you know a slurpee is a bit low
brow
where a milkshake could be a gourmet
artisanal milkshake
they have pistachio they have chunks of
peanut butter cups
they have places that are famous for
their milkshakes they have places that
mix stuff there's blueberry milkshakes
this homemade you can make milkshakes
you can't make a slurpee at home
you can you can't make a slurpee at home
because they're perfect and you need a
special machine there's malt
shops you go girls on roller skates
you get yourself a shake it goes down
the 50s
you can make mixed drinks with me with
uh slurpees you can't do that with
milkshakes nobody's drinking
i was on metropolitan avenue in
williamsburg two nights ago
there was a place dedicated to spiked
milkshakes shut your mouth
milkshakes were invented in 1885 and
first served with whiskey
they were first served with them oh my
god i'm gonna start talking like you
nobody on this planet had ever bought a
slurpee and lived to tell the tale
you just say [ __ ] what year did slurpee
i'm telling you right now i'm telling
you right now
we'll go to a 7-eleven if somebody walks
out with a slurpee we just go right up
to him it'll be a gorilla interview we
say can we talk to you about your life
how
are things going i guarantee you half
them go not so good
what is your problem because because
when you're gonna hit the backbone of
this kind of
7-eleven the slurpee if i'm choosing to
get a 64-ounce
sugar it gets to amps oh really
google mike bloomberg he tried to put a
ban on it
he tried to ban because so many people
get the 64 ounce it was a political
problem
all right all right potentially all
right
that a milkshake melted is somehow good
who likes drinking ice cream water who
likes drinking that it's disgusting
it doesn't become ice cream water it
just becomes cream who likes drinking
cream you weirdo
i mean like everyone dude everyone cream
is like one of the best things in the
world it's like butter
cream is everything you drink every
cream you would drink a glass of cream
no but
ice cream is cream and when it melts it
becomes cream it doesn't require you
water it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter ice creams a lot of things and
when it melts it becomes something else
would you mean
room temperature ice cream is gross room
temperature slurpee
well i'm not saying it's not but stop
acting like your drink is so much better
when it goes to [ __ ] it's not
i didn't i mean i didn't
certainly joe can be cold as it melts a
little bit and becomes
a more creamy
[Laughter]
you know you are a human piece of [ __ ]
you're a human piece of [ __ ]
god go go slurp it up get as many
slurpees as you want every time you take
a slurp you pull a month off your life
let's go to the slurp let's go let's go
to the bottom
and say we did that's like i'm giving
you pee herman lines now
how about this just just the disgusting
name slurp when you slurp something up
that is onomatopoeia that's disgusting
it's nate it's an animal it's named at
the
slurpee yeah
no it's not disgusting too 480
000 beautiful decent americans every day
don't think that slurping is is ugly or
disgusting
i like icees in moderation but if i'm
comparing them against
this the milkshake i will tell you all
the problems a slurpee
has all right it's food court babe i
gotta come up with that i gotta tell you
the reasons i don't like a slurry i want
to see some comments we got it we got
people
are in a bad way if they're drinking
slurpees on the reg
slurpees are free once a year and is a
go-to on a hot day
milkshake is a once in a while dessert
it's always the same it makes me [ __ ] my
brains out
yes ryan is correct i mean
whatever i mean i don't even like i
don't think that's a strong argument
jared says
a lot of people have [ __ ] issues for
milkshakes milkshake is a once a once in
a while dessert what is a slurpee
if if this dude is a go-to on a hot day
i agree with this
man isn't that also a once in a while
dessert did you ever get a house you're
telling me that a slurpee you ever get a
slurpee and walk around the city holding
a slurpee it's amazing i'm not a psycho
it's amazing nobody walks around with a
milkshake
you can't say a slurpee is free once a
year and it's a once in a while thing
and then
see the same exact thing as a negative
for a milkshake by the way
by the way you want to talk about the
state of somebody's life this is what a
pile of [ __ ] you are when you get a
milkshake
they give you a silver cup with extra
cause they know
they're like you're the kind of guy
that's why that wants something that's
not why don't try it
don't try to change the narrative
there's no food where they give you
seconds
automatically they give you extra they
give you extra because it costs a lot of
money
and they want to give you the whole
thing that they're making out of it
don't don't don't try and change it
two drinks they give you extra width
milkshake and martini
because they know where your life says
i can't wait to go slurp this up i want
to get a
slurpee i'm just like you know who's a
slurpee you
no no you become a slurpee you're the
slurpee you
are the slurpee when you buy a slurpee
you're the slurper to slurp
yours you become a slurpee i you slurpee
that drink up no you're the slurper the
slurpee is being slurped
oh well the slurpee is the slurpee there
all right whatever that's just a fun
little thing
even people yeah
and use a straw when i was younger but
when i but but but when i take a
i just can't wait to go slurp up
what's in this cup i'm going to slurp it
all up into my mouth
this guy or this person claims to even
people that are lactose intolerant will
go through the pain
to have a milkshake let's keep scrolling
pimp please
oh milkshake forget it slurpees are for
12 year olds and under
you put a scoop of ice cream on a cherry
a lot of people top it with whipped
cream
until any adult drinking a slurpee is
also like
swisher sweets that's true that's very
okay right now you as a child right now
just bookmark that that might be
a child yes y'all you want a milkshake
or a slurpee i think that child
boom eyes light up milkshake i'd rather
have a slurpee right above the one you
just start i'd rather have a slurpee or
a slush puppy
than a milkshake that was disappointing
if i asked for chocolate
don't just show the bosco to the blender
dump that [ __ ] in
yes exactly yeah don't get us don't get
a shake there you idiot
well don't get a surprise from a busting
slurpee machine
that's a slushy vans versus all right
sorry
keep going i never get to all right keep
going
uh slurpees have zero nutritional value
i mean what kind of animal are you
if you're looking to a milkshake for
nutritional value
i mean no offense lila whatever her name
is yeah lila
slurpees have your nutritional value and
are harmful to your blood glucose levels
they are
milkshakes aren't what are we talking
about here but a slurpee is poison in
disguise let's be honest
it's straight up poison if you turn it
over and look at the ingredients there's
not one natural ingredient in the thing
this chick
is arguing electrolytes and vitamin d on
behalf of milkshakes
that's insane that's insane well when
she's drawing a comparison to that it's
basically water with poison the slurpee
i mean what are we even talking about
here a gas station cup of coffee
or sorry i guess there's a cup of slop
versus ice cream teamed up with milk and
whipped cream with a cherry no we're not
talking about a gas station slot we're
talking about slurpees yeah but that's
711 is our gas station but it's a gas
station food bro
um
as classy this is insane to me right are
you kidding me at least milkshakes are
on menus in real restaurants across the
country
and slurpee in three places all those
fancy 7-eleven
gas station 7-eleven gas station yeah
denny's daddy's proponent of the
proprietor of the milkshake friendlies
you're right
these are nice spots these are better
than a gas station
711 is not a gas station it's a
convenience it can be but it's
accumulated so it's
a lot of times it's connected to a gas
station don't act like you don't know
that
look at me don't act like you don't know
that no don't no i won't do it go to the
gas station in fact there's no
if i'm not correct pimp there is no such
thing as a 7-eleven gas station or is
there is there
there is okay well i don't know if the
the gas is 7-eleven but there's plenty
of seven-dollars
all right i'm wrong all right i'm wrong
i'm wrong i'll drop it i'm wrong
uh this isn't even fair because you can
literally hook up any syrup to a slurpee
machine but it
but how it's how my super secret slurpee
spot
back in michigan was the first to roll
out verner soda and
faygo slurpees years before anyone okay
well he's he's i that one didn't make
sense slurpee sounds like a bad std
it's so rough like the kind where the
medication side effects are probably
worse than the disease symptoms
symptoms milkshake is king all right
look we got to go to the polls here
uh also blue blue's awesome
blue is not all sleaze dude blue is our
winner is the uh
the swisher sweets person uh at doug
coffin follow at
d-o-u-g c-o-f-f-i-n thank you doug
we liked the tweet quite a bit and now
let's go to the polls
what do you think sal i well here's what
i think okay
32 000 votes oh jesus
um it's gonna be uh i don't know man
cause i i
milk shakes ah man slurpees are
everywhere slurpees are everywhere
i honestly don't know which way i don't
honestly don't know which way this is
gonna go right now
i really don't know pimp
63.5 to 36.5 milkshake
33 000 votes take that l
and slurp it all right see you later i
still love you
love you too third loss in a row
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds